[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to reboot
GameSpot's opinion editorial show I'm
your host Mike McCarty and I'm Jake
Decker and as always in our off week of
this bi weekly show we do a QA based on
the last episode and possibly talked a
little bit about the next episode we
want to do and throughout the coming
season last week we put up a video about
Hell blade so I know a sacrifice my
favorite episode we've done so far yeah
mine too I think you kind of got a
little bit deeper than I thought we
would with this game if you want to go
check it out people over in our UK
office tomorrow and Adam did a really
great video about why Hell blade is
important from a business standpoint in
terms of Double A development kind of
these smaller indie companies that are
making like Triple A looking in triple-a
level games without the massive funding
of bigger studios that's and why it's
important in that way and that's a great
video to watch so we decided to accolade
more from game design standpoint and if
you haven't watched the episode yet last
week reboot reboot episode 12 go back
and watch it it was about how hell blade
tackles like mental illness and other
games have done it before we'll get into
that with the questions which we'll get
into and like 20 seconds but I think
he'll blade put the mental illness
specifically psychosis in the case of
the protagonist seonhwa at the center of
the gameplay which is pretty bold and it
was even more amazing to see how
faithfully they did it they brought on
two psychologists from University of
Cambridge and the other names were right
at the beginning of the credits too yeah
they brought them on to consult and make
sure that they were doing the psychosis
aspects service in terms of audio the
binaural audio in the headphones and the
actual hallucinations and how the
puzzles fit into Santa's delusions and
how her detachment from the world
actually you know like resonated with
some of the patients that these
psychiatrist had worked with and they
consulted with them as well so it was a
pretty effective effective game in that
respect so yeah we do as always have a
few questions I had a comment on the
video asking other people what other
games deal well with mental illness in a
meaningful way and Jake you want to be
the first response I believe this was an
answer to that question sure it's by TN
law 2004 the Silent Hill games
especially Silent Hill 2 usually have
characters facing serious issues often
in their own mind yeah I'm a big
survival horror kind of horror
fan I used to do a podcast with
medication she was still here and I
cover our horror games somehow like
whenever they come out here at GameSpot
and the Silent Hill game for some games
I grew up on and I agree they always had
some sort of you know like
hallucinations or psychological horror
and psychological thriller aspects yeah
I don't think any of the games
meaningfully put it at the center of the
game but I think they used it well to
characterize some of the the actual
characters in it it was - wasn't it that
basically everything you saw or your
character saw was a manifestation of her
past and like kind of a twisted take on
it yeah they kind of she kind of had
like some PTSD from trauma in the past
and lost which is similar to hell blade
but they used it to good effect I think
there so thank you TN law 2004 moving on
to another youtube comment from wreck
soul whether you like Hell blade or not
this game is a permanent landmark in the
history of video games they proved that
small studios can do better without
millionaire financing of giant
publishers that limit their creativity
it proved that games can deal with
serious subjects to prove that games can
leave the pattern everyone else follows
yeah we touched on that and like I said
our UK team here at GameSpot did a more
kind of inside baseball but still very
interesting video on how you know Double
A games are making a reamer gence this
year especially hell-blade being
foremost among those but yeah this game
on a few different levels is really
important we decided to talk again about
- you like emotional aspects and how the
gameplay that design itself can be fun
but in a way that shouldn't be fun I
would say but it still makes use of the
main characters like a pretty serious
issue and but it's it's pretty
interesting that they managed to
structure a game around that so when how
blade finally came out a bunch of us
were kind of like slowly starting to say
this game is really great and you should
try it out did you know much about how
blade before came out I knew almost
nothing I think I saw I saw a couple
trailers as it was as they were ramping
up towards their launch and the trailers
I thought were really interesting but I
had no idea that it was going to be that
focused on mental illness I figured it
would just be another hack and slash
game with probably a strong story cuz
DMC did have a pretty strong story if I
remember correctly so yeah I knew almost
nothing going into this game very happy
I played it though yeah the combat was
one of the points that a lot of people
say takes away from this game I love the
combat I can see why it's a little
I can see why some people would say it
doesn't necessarily fit and I think
maybe there's a little bit too much
combat in it but I thought the combat
was a lot of fun as bare-bones as it is
yeah it's weird it's like over the
shoulder melee not just like the
third-person Devil May Cry God of War
action it's actually looks like what
they're gonna do with the new god of war
you over-the-shoulder Kratos I'm saying
it's another like for honor sure that
makes sense to me as like the actual
fixed camera over someone other than a
free-flowing like character action game
I'm interested to see what God of War
does and God of War is also Norse
mythology
so yeah Rexel thank you so much for
writing in on youtube Jake you want to
take the next one yeah this one's from I
think that's this ones from surf and
bacon from surfer and bacon I think I
think it's surf and bacon
yeah okay I've heard a lot of people say
that she isn't the first display of
mental illness in a game Batman Max
Payne etc but she's the first display of
mental illness where that mental illness
takes the forefront of the story the
setting the plot the game mechanics all
of it is made with the constant presence
of her psychosis and mind rather than
just dreams or flashback sequences that
is only a minor part of the game yeah it
was a Max Payne 3 when he was just
essentially an alcoholic and to get to
Grieg ain't health you were just popping
painkillers and then he was dealing with
PTSD and stuff from depression and yeah
depression his family died right got
killed I was if I might be
misremembering I'm pretty sure his
daughter and wife died and yeah Batman
you have like the Scarecrow sequences
and Batman I think the most interesting
Batman stories to me always play like
kind of on his psyche different
different graphic novels or movies will
play on a different aspect I remember
Batman Begins central theme is fear and
I really like that and Arkham Asylum
which i think is still the best of that
trilogy and if you disagree with me we
can hash that out at a later date but in
Arkham Asylum yet when you're fighting
scarecrow you're kind of doing he's just
massive in the background and I really
like that but I do agree with surf and
bacon that it kind of is the focal point
here and it drives the entire game in a
very sad but a very in a way that I
don't think another medium could do can
you think of any other games that deal
with kind of like trauma loss or
anything like people had mentioned
SpecOps the
a lot in the comments spec ops the line
is a good one I mean this is a kind of
different depression quest though yeah
depression quest very much that's very
much more on the nose yeah it's a little
bit more on the nose yeah so II Quinn
made that about just like depression in
the modern age I'd say which I actually
haven't played but I've yeah I've seen
heard a lot about it actually a lot of
it a game that we've actually talked
about a couple times which doesn't miss
isn't necessarily like on mental illness
but papers please is very hectic I guess
very stressful and like you I don't know
if that's a good example it's about
empathy though you kind of empathy yeah
there's nothing like you know how to win
the game but there are some characters
that are just so like really trying to
ask you for mercy that you feel bad like
not letting them across the border even
though you know that your pay will get
docked or you might lose your job and
it's pretty tough and I think those
games are important beginner's guide
beginners who played the beginner's
guide but that game deals that game is
the game is all kind of a different case
because it's more about getting in the
headspace of a game developer but this
game developer in particular was is
afraid of sharing what he's made and I
think that plays into paranoia stress
depression a little bit but that one
that one's way more abstract I'd say
then then this yeah so played a surf and
bacon thank you for your question and
last one that we picked out for this
week Carlos Rodriguez on YouTube as well
said one of the most thought-provoking
games I played was this war of mine I
found the decisions and backdrop to be
haunting leading me to reflect on what
was happening in the world and how some
people may have to make real-world
choices in the same light yeah
definitely other game we've talked about
and rebooted for some of the comments in
the on youtube and on our site we're
saying this episode reminded them of the
war episode we did what other games
could portray war better and this war
mine was one of our examples of how it
they can it uses the gameplay to kind of
emphasize this deeper point you know
just for clarification some of my
favorite games ever made are dumb and
they're very fun and they don't try to
tackle psychosis issues they don't try
to tackle broader aspects of war they
don't try to
you you know they don't try shoot aliens
yes you're bringing up X's on you're
gonna derail me yeah XCOM to is one of
my favorite games were made actually I'm
gonna I was just about to say Majora's
Mask is my favorite game ever made and
if you want to really get into that game
definitely deals with ya grief and
oppression grief loss if you want to get
into some really really hardcore fan
theories of which I have delved very
deep into from Majora's Mask a lot of
people think Majora's Mask if you know
the game there are four main areas like
kind of for dungeons and for area
structured around that in the land of
termina outside of the overworld and
then inside the overworld and outside of
Clock Town any people think that's one
of the stages of grief and then there's
the you know before and after but each
dungeons like one is bargaining one is
depression
one is anger I could go in more depth
but I want to get the rail because
Majora's Mask is my favorite game of all
time and maybe that has something to do
with it I really liked it it's very dark
and gloomy and oppressive rather than
you know time I mentioned in hell-blade
that time gets distorted a lot and
that's kind of a constant thing I
mention in the video that in one way or
another through myself or like people
I'm close to have seen a lot of these
kind of problems up close and majora's
mask was one of those things where it
was that was really impressive as well i
that didn't put it at the forefront as
much as hell-blade did but if you go
back and play majora's mask now I came
is dark and it's a Nintendo it was a
Nintendo game they were following up on
the most successful one of the most
successful games ever made and not to
mention like they had to close out the
n64 before they brought in the Gamecube
I still can't believe that Majora's Mask
exists as it does now but if you want to
if you're watching this go read up on
Majora's Mask but yes Carlos Rodriguez
this war of mine does make you make some
tough decisions not in the same way not
as a serious movie but XCOM does as well
and the new expansion for XCOM actually
also deals much more with the stress
aspect some of your characters will have
negative traits like if one of their
bond mates like their favorite friend in
XCOM dies or gets hurt they will have a
fear of that kind of alien that killed
them and though something will trigger
in them they'll panic or they'll get
really angry some of them will become
obsessive because they've sir
by doing this one action so many times
they'll start doing that without you
telling them to it's really cool and you
know it is we mentioned the PTSD aspects
of in the war episode of shooter games
how that can sometimes help with PTSD or
sometimes you know trigger it but this
war of mine is definitely a great
example and one of the ones that I'm
glad we got to touch on this episode
again that game is really special and
people more people should play when they
get a chance Jake any last thoughts on
hell-blade or like ninja theory in
general uh I mean I if you haven't
played hell blade it's definitely worth
it I think it's I think it's it's
probably in my top five games so far
this year obviously there's still more
to come out but I absolutely love that I
don't know if I'll play it again ever I
don't think so because it is it can be
tough to get through but it is really
good yeah definitely and and I don't
often say this but it might not be your
thing but I would definitely tell
everyone to try hell-blade do you want
to kind of subtly tease an ex episode we
said we won't do this all the time but I
think we're pretty fairly certain I'll
be out of town for the next two weeks so
we're gonna be working from across the
country on the next episode so hopefully
we have decided on the episode do you
want to subtly tease it well let's see
we typically talk about games they're
recent games or timely or very upcoming
or timely so I think coming up soon
uh I don't know what comes out of the
beginning descent or September yeah what
comes out destiny yeah and so obviously
the old opinion editorials show for news
about what the point and Danny or Dwyer
was always really critical of destiny in
terms of its design we're gonna look at
destiny in a way most people don't
always and I won't say whether it's
positive or negative I don't know that
it will be either positive or negative
but we're gonna kind of look at Bungie
and how important Bungie is to the
modern design landscape because a lot of
people know that a lot of people know
how halo kind of sparked the Xbox and
halo to spark the Xbox Live etc but
we're gonna look kind of throughout like
do a pretty brief history of Bungie and
why games today exist like they do
because of Bungie and how fun they've
made first-person shooters etc so that
one should be fun and we're gonna bring
destiny into it and I'll share some more
thoughts on destiny
this will be like a week before destiny
two reviews come up so should get people
primed and ready to go for a game that
from what I played seems better than the
first game but again I don't know for
sure I haven't played it that much but
I'm looking forward to it it'll kick off
the fall season and we'll have plenty of
things to talk about on reboot so we're
looking forward to it
destiny sucks and that is episode 12.5
of reboot thank you guys for tuning in
and make sure to leave your comments
below we'll definitely be checking those
and make sure to subscribe and come back
next week so you can see what
shenanigans we were up to see you then
see ya
[Music]